Magnus Carlson is a machine with an
accuracy score of 98.2 the former world
champion was in Elite level form in his
Clash against world number three Fabiano
caruana in the aim chess rapid finish
off the first game Magnus discovered
Mateen 6 in seconds Bobby has Queen
resigned drawing the second game game
three followed a very familiar line a
repeat of the 2018 World Championship
Match David wow Deja Vu Magnus made a
clever attempt to force stalemate Bobby
didn't fall for it but the result was
the same going into the final game a
draw was all Magnus needed to clinch
Victory fabi's chances collapsed after
rook d8 and that's why